do you think these memos are part of the
evidence that a prosecutor Robert Muller
or somebody else should be considering
when determining the president's intent
it's my recollection that is the
evidence that will be used if there was
ever proceeding these would be to show
that I wrote it down at the time sort of
the bolster the credibility of my
recollection James Comey talking about
the memos that were released to Capitol
Hill now there was an inspector general
report we can confirm into how he
handled those memos and whether they
were classified at the time at the same
time the Democratic Party has filed a
lawsuit and they are suing this list of
people Donald Trump jr. Paul Manafort
Roger stone Jared Kushner Rick gates the
Russian government the Donald Trump
campaign WikiLeaks and George
papadopolis all those people named in
the DNC lawsuit and even some Democrats
on Capitol Hill having an issue with
that I actually think this lawsuit is
ill-conceived and I am not very
supportive of it I think we have a very
serious criminal activity underway in
this country by the Russians and
possibly by those within the Trump
campaign and to make this political is
actually the wrong thing to be doing I'm
not interested in a political tip for
tat I'm interested in getting to the
truth and if there's criminal conduct
that has been engaged in holding people
accountable okay with that there's a lot
of news to get into let's bring in our
panel Tom Rogan commentary writer for
the Washington Examiner Leslie Marshall
syndicated talk radio host and match
flap contributor with the hill okay Matt
let's start with the DNC you know some
people saying this is a fundraising
gambit others saying this is an effort
to get people to be deposed and continue
this thing even if these investigations
wrap up how do you see it it is the
dumbest political move I've seen in a
long time because it makes it all about
politics those of us who go on TV every
day and explain that that this whole
investigation with Russia is a canard
and it's about the Denver
that's making politics the DNC just
confirmed it and the irony of this is
trey Gowdy said earlier on Fox is the
the irony of that is if anybody has a
beef on collusion and rigging something
it's Bernie Sanders with what the then
DNC chairman debbie Wasserman Schultz
did with that nominating process so I
don't I can't get inside their heads to
see what their motivation was but as a
Republican it's pretty pretty stupid
within while you share that opinion with
the president United States so within
the past few minutes actually seven
minutes ago he just tweeted out just
heard the campaign was sued by the
obstructionist Democrats this can be
good news in that we will now counter
for the DNC server that they refused to
give to the FBI the wendy Wasserman
Schultz servers and documents held by
Pakistani mystery-man and Clinton emails
Debbie I'm sure he's talking about
debbie Wasserman Schultz but the
president obviously weighing in saying
that they'll go after the Democrats for
all of that and both sides are wrong for
doing this yes Matt don't faint I agree
with you a little bit hear what the
American people want is less of this
right they want less of the swamp they
want less of both Democrats and
Republicans and the president certainly
to be in the weeds again the president
constantly says there's a witch-hunt
there's no collusion just let Muller do
his job let the investigation play out
everything else is a distraction Comey
is a distraction this lawsuit is a
distraction the president's tweets are a
distraction and the president responding
in the way that he's threatening to
respond this via another distraction I
don't think it helps either party or the
president Tom yeah look I mean it's
inherently politicized now and I think
the blurring most people watching this
certainly my grandfather last night one
of those watching the show with him is
there is the perception that everything
whether it be McCabe Comey the president
the DNC today comes together and it's
inherently politicized and the problem
with that ultimately is that when the
country when the final decision comes
whether it be from Muller or any of
these investigations a lot of the
country is just not going to believe it
and so the credibility of institutions
the capital the high
you know that is something that is
suffering here in the coma memos January
28th 2017 one of the memos he says this
I explained that he could count on me to
always tell him the truth talking to the
president there I said I don't do sneaky
things I don't leak
I don't do weasel moves obviously he
leaked those memos to his friend and now
there's an IG investigation whether
those memos contain classified
information right and he didn't tell the
president that this sex stuff the
dossier was funded by the DNC and the
Hillary Clinton campaign and his
political opponents and obviously Jim
Comey went before Congress and in two
different topics in two separate months
in sequential months gave different
answers as to whether or not the
president put political pressure on him
to open or shut the investigation on
Mike Flynn the problem with Jim Comey is
that he has an amazing lack of how he is
coming across to the American people he
lacks so much credibility and I think
these memos do nothing nothing to add
anything to his side of the equation
that somehow the president was acting
inappropriately well Democrats say they
they show that he has the same thoughts
then as he has now when he wrote it down
extemporaneously elected Democrats in
Congress
all right few occasions he gave
different testimony in May of 17 that he
gave in June of 17 he's got to deal with
Congress on that all right let's see if
I can get this one House committee
chairs good lat gaudí and Nunez on the
Comey memos they write this the memos
also show former director Comey never
wrote that he felt obstructed or
threatened he never once mentioned the
most relevant fact of all which was
whether he felt obstructed in his
investigation the memos show Comey was
blind to biases within the FBI and had
terrible judgment with respect to his
deputy Andrew McCabe on multiple
occasions he and his own words defended
the character of McCabe after President
Trump questioned McCabe Lesley I have to
say that when when I heard he was
writing a book I was hoping he wouldn't
do some of what he did two of the things
that bother me as a Democrat or one
really stooping to the juvenile level of
some of the president's tweets talking
about his hand
talking about his hair but to even
talking about Russia obstruction of
justice can obstruct in a sense the
entire investigation and derail what's
already been done so I definitely have a
problem with that it's obvious that this
man was angry that he was fired and many
of us are many people in Washington
write books afterward I I don't think
that Comey has helped himself with this
if he's planning on running for office
but I don't think it's going to weigh in
to Democrats I think quite the opposite
Republicans one of these memos released
if anything I don't think it makes Comey
look as bad as the president based on
the president's response and the
president's behavior according to those
memos and really caring more about his
cell phone coming off as paranoid we'll
see how this all goes again I interview
Comey Jim Comey on Thursday